morning guys today i'm going to give you
a day in the life of what being a
youtuber is like so today i have a shoot
so
i'm going to go get the supplies for the
shoot all right we got our signs for
today
boom
boom all right so next i gotta get my
coffee because
i need coffee to do it for to do one of
these shoes
so i ran into ish how are we doing good
we're ready for today's shoot what do
you think of the signs i got they're
going to be explosive very very
explosive okay i'll see you in a bit
i was walking with the signs he drove
past i was like perfect i don't have to
carry him anymore okay y'all car is
packed
we're ready to go say hi niko
so now we're setting up for the set
setting up setting up we have a security
guard today
yeah yeah
i'm sorry guys i forgot to give you the
footage like when we were filming but
ish how do we how did filming go today
well well got a lot of interviews um
some people nice some people not so nice
but it's gonna be posted on my youtube
channel